and talk to me about the crowd tonight i
mean it was absolutely insane just from
in our room here we can just hear the
noise the roar from the crowd
how did it feel like to walk out to a
full arena once again
it sucked man people were yelling all
kind of crazy stuff as i was walking to
the ring
we couldn't hear that part yeah i could
i could hear it because it's directed
right at me but uh it's all good you
know
i'm just happy i'm in a place where i
don't care about that stuff i hear it
but it's just
whatever your mental game seems to have
just improved so much and i was trying
to go with burns just a moment ago as
well about coming back from that loss
against camaro usman and having to get
your mentality right as well
if you were to give a percentage to the
physical training and then the mental
work you do i know your nutrition
spot on and everything you do with
metabolic tracking all that kind of
thing but if you were to put a
percentage on the mental side of things
and growth that you've had
what would you say it is um
over the last you know it kind of
started when my daughter was born but i
would say over the last three years
has been uh and i don't know if it's
like my mentality towards fighting or
just life in general just
kind of focusing on what matters and
what i can't control and and
that's it you know whether it be goals
that i set outside of fighting or goals
in fighting
or critics or opinions i kind of just
know what's important and uh
i know who i am so people can't tell me
who i am you know i know who this guy is
when i look in the mirror so that's kind
of just just growing up i guess
just having a daughter bring that out of
you as well yeah i can't wait to go home
tomorrow to see her
um yeah it does
it and it honestly makes you look at
life in perspective and
makes me like when i was younger without
a daughter i was just fighting and i
didn't care about you know getting
damaged and
but now i think about my daughter um you
know five weeks an emotional week for me
because
i know this is dangerous so that's why
i'm kind of says stuff like that
you know about death and stuff like that
it really it really
touches me